what seemed to me to to resonate
uh around you with folks that i did not
expect was that
you really never seemed to dislike
anybody on the campaign trail
you didn't dislike people didn't agree
with you you didn't dislike people who
insulted you you didn't dislike the
people you were running against you
spoke
um fondly and with a lot of empathy um
of towards people on the other side the
way you framed your
your your policies had that dimension
you're talking about the bernie sanders
and
imagine yourself to the left of him but
one way people
experience politics isn't just
ideological it's also
on this axis of confrontationalness
and you had a pretty um distinctive like
left policy agenda
but on the confrontational axis you were
way down right you would talk to people
democrats would
rarely talk to go on programs they would
rarely go on and and even now on twitter
i think you very self-consciously
cultivate a very nice persona
in a very unnice space and i'd like to
hear a bit about how you
you think about that because whether it
was all authentic i think there's at
least some recognition that it has power
now
and given that it's a pretty basic thing
i think it probably had more power than
you would have expected or certainly
than i
would have expected wow ezra i hadn't
thought of it
in in those terms but i mean you've
known me for a while so you know that
the nice thing is a complete facade
that that i'm actually naturally very
bitter
um now it's it's the case that i
like most americans and then i think
that
there have been massive problems that
have been built up over decades and
decades
and you wrote a book on polarization and
why we're polarized
and i feel like people have gotten
driven into different corners and pitted
against each other
in a way that's unproductive i naturally
don't get angry at people that disagree
with me i kind of expect a degree of
political
uh asynchrony because you know it's like
not like someone's gonna believe
everything you believe
and one of the things that i did find
running for president was that
the media would often try and goad me
into conflicts
it would be like this person said this
what do you think about that and
and the dynamic was supposed to foment
an expression of outrage
and then i would say something that
seemed to me to be like
the natural reaction but i just think
that the outrage
cycle is very very negative
uh and i think a lot of americans
including me are very tired of it
but i can genuinely say it wasn't really
a strategy on my part and it's not a
strategy now
except in so far as when i'm
putting out a message i just find it
more productive for me to be
positive than for me to throw a rock at
somebody
it always struck me too that it
reflected in part the media you came up
through
so i think when most democrats run for
president they think about getting
coverage on
you know msnbc and in in democratic or
liberal aligned publications which have
which tend to reward a more
confrontational approach and that's true
also for
for centrist publications right you you
have a great story on your blog about
being at an early iowa
event and like all the reporters are
there to hear michael avenatti including
like the centrist reporters who just
want
conflict but you came up i mean you're
on my on this podcast pretty early in
your campaign but you did joe rogan's
podcast my friend sam harris
um you were on like a lot of youtube
world things
and that's some that's a it's a very
political space and sometimes it can be
even an angry space but it's
it's like a more mixed space you have
like a lot of fans on reddit and 4chan
and that struck me as uh like informing
your approach way through that that
those are different worlds to talk to
where people have different political
concerns
and it always struck me that you ended
up representing a slightly less
polarized media in what
ended up working for you and what you
then were rewarded for saying
and and representing in politics ezra i
genuinely went where they would have me
like that's where initially the like the
the msnbc's and cnn's
um and you know centrist publications
were not very excited to have me on
frankly so if you were me and you were
like who wants to talk to me
like hey do you want to talk to me it's
one reason i'm grateful to you because
you had me on
when others were not and so i'm grateful
to you and i've always seen you as a
very very
smart back driven purveyor of
what you regard as truth you know and
and it's you know it's
one reason i appreciate you in this
conversation so much
and i did not get that vibe from some
other
outlets and journalists and so you know
it really was a necessity being the
mother of invention where i would talk
to
people that would have me on um and a
lot of those folks were youtubers
and podcasters and folks who didn't have
a cable network behind
them yeah it's a and it worked i mean
i want to get to ubi so we won't spend
all the time looking at retrospective of
your campaign but
but it did just strike me as
i thought you and pete buddha judge did
the best job of this and you did
something differently right i don't
think people judge would have gone on
ben shapiro's show and
and debated circumcision like that
wasn't his vibe but there was a
like joe biden for his virtues
has a very old media view of politics
and also doesn't do that much media
and a lot of democrats would come up
through through the ranks for a long
time
like they saw media very much i would
call it the way it was in 2005.
and now there's this burbling fractured
and it can be very
polarized but it also can be very mixed
up in a way that can be useful
world out there and that if you're a lot
of it has
much more audience than people um i
think in the mainstream media recognize
you know what some of these folks on
youtube are able to command is in the
millions it um
it it rivals the cable networks but it
doesn't have
like the mainstream establishment uh
respect
that say a cable network does and so it
gets ignored
but it's no worse a way to to reach
people and i think reddit had that
quality for you too like you're very big
on rashes on reddit yesterday
and you're involved i guess in some
california data privacy initiative and
had 23
000 upvotes just noting that you were
part of it
so these are these are pretty different
worlds and and i wonder how much you
think
the democratic party or just traditional
politics politicians in general
are missing them and and leaving these
worlds unspoken to
well this to me is uh something we
should talk about more ezra because i
think the shifting media landscape
is going to impact politics very
dramatically
and some folks are going to be late to
it like you're on top of it just from
that line of questioning but
if you look at the cable news audiences
you're looking at
the low millions and it tends to be like
the same two million people over and
over again
and you're talking about a massive
population of
you know tens of millions of voters and
so you hit it on the head
where if you look at the audience of
some of the biggest
podcasts it goes into the millions it
is higher than the cable newscasts
and the cable newscast drive this media
narrative
bubble that then gets self-reinforcing
and then everyone looks out
out and says like hey aren't you
concerned about whatever the heck we
were concerned about yesterday
and meanwhile like they're just
listening to joe rogan or whomever
you know like that they they're getting
a very different
perspective and they're hearing about
issues that
are more relevant to them than a lot of
the dc oriented
issues the biggest example of that on
the trail was impeachment i don't think
i got a single question about
impeachment
the entire time and then and this was
when he was actually getting impeached
you know so so there are different
conversations happening
and it would be very beneficial for
politicians generally but democrats in
particular to start trying to broaden
their universe
because what you don't want to do is
just end up in a world where just
talking to each other and then wondering
why
no one's listening to you and and that's
the danger and one of the things that
i like about these different worlds as
somebody who i try to spend a certain
amount of my media diet
in subcultures that are not my main one
um
because i think it's important to know
how their argumentative universes work
and
what they consider important and
unimportant and this to me was always
the secret of your campaign that people
didn't quite realize
uh that politics washington politics
has developed a set of things that it
considers like the questions of the day
the week the month a year
um so you know at a certain point it's
impeachment which is very very
it was important like i ran an
impeachment podcast and i think it's
important what was happening there
um but taxes health care i mean these
are these are real things
you might ask how did this guy andrew
yang get on joe rogan and some of these
other shows
because he doesn't allow just anybody on
that's a big show he has a lot of
options about who comes on
and there's this whole world that is
very
focused on ai risk and what that's going
to do
and how that's going to change things
and when you came up and wanted to
move that up as an issue in politics
increase
like as a political scientist would say
increase in salience and politics
there was a world of people there for
that because they were already having
that conversation but nobody in politics
was like
politics reflected the the set of
issues that washington thought was
important and understood how to talk
about
but it's not the only set of issues
people care about and so then there are
these whole worlds
that are really underserved in terms of
their concerns and
like what always struck me as an
interesting bypass you took into this
was like the value of your campaign to
me was it it elevated concerns that
deserve more attention in politics than
they typically
get not just solutions but concerns and
you know that i have a different view on
a lot of the ai economic risk than you
do at least somewhat
but um but there's no doubt that it
should be talked about
and so you went where people were
talking about it and i think there was a
lot of surprise
that so many people were so uh were so
concerned and so
engaged on this and so ready for a
candidate to try to say
no this should be one of the ten issues
we talk about like let's move something
else out of the frame
yeah that's right ezra where if you talk
to techies they're much more concerned
about ai
and as you know the the central
argument-wide campaign around automation
than a lot of other americans and
they were happy to talk to a political
figure who was
talking about something that they'd been
thinking about for months or years
and one of the funny byproducts of it
all was that
i ended up having conversations with
people that didn't feel terribly
political if you know what i mean it was
like look
like what's going on uh with ai like
what should we be concerned about
like what does that competitive
landscape with china look like over time
and because of that i ended up reaching
audiences that
generally did not consider themselves
super political
and hopefully i did broaden the range of
concerns that
we should be looking at as a country it
wasn't very deliberate on my part i mean
i just cared about what i cared about
went to folks who also cared about it
but it is a sign how
both dc and the media have this
relationship where there's like a set of
prescribed concerns that may or may not
line up with
the concerns around the country thank
you for listening in i hope you enjoyed
this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]